I know,
I know that I have to ask this
because this is one of the,
I've seen you answer this question,
is that do you believe in God?
And I saw a youtube video with you
when you said that you didn't like the
question because you were,
you were being boxed in.
And I sort of,
I,
I felt that because one of the things me
and my wife had been wrestling with is
we've talked a lot about this.
What do we mean when we say that we
believe in God because in Sweden to be
Swedish,
to be Christian,
it was sort of what it means
today to say that you are Swedish.
So if you said that you were a Christian,
you were sort of a good family father,
you had a lot of values within that
being like a good Christian man is.
So today when you say
you're a good Swedish brand,
perhaps,
so it used to mean a lot more,
but then you had the,
the Evangelical Christians,
uh,
criticizing exactly this and saying that
you are lost contact with God and then
they meant it in a much smaller sense.
Okay.
And so they tend to confuse the
biblical stories with lit with empirical
history.
Yeah,
and it's not surprising they do that
because they're trying to defend their
faith against,
let's call it the postmodern assault
or even the modernist assault for that
matter.
I have some sympathy
with their motivations,
but the problem is,
is that they don't understand that not
all truth is empirical truth in in fact
the fundamental truths as far as I
could tell paradoxically enough our
Darwinian,
and they actually line
up with religious truths,
which is the point that I've been
trying to make when I discussed this.
Such issues with people like Sam Harris.
Like Sam is a very,
very smart guy,
but he's,
he worships the intellect.
That's the first thing I would say.
And the second thing is that I was
never able to push him to his solution.
He'd never let me go
there because you know,
his idea is that we could rationally
order society so that the wellbeing of
people was maximized.
And you know,
he even said to,
I think it was,
I can't remember which interview it was,
but he said explicitly to the
person that he was interviewing,
that he could sit down right now and
come up with a religious system that was
much more rational,
inappropriate than any of the ones
that have that have existed to date.
And I think,
well,
you know,
you're falling right into that
rationalist Utopian pitfall there.
Your nurse,
not that smart.
No one can do that.
And as soon as you do it,
you end up where the socialists,
like the radical Soviet socialists
or the Nazi utopians ended up,
we will be speaking as
grown by now though.
Yeah.
Well,
yes,
exactly.
Except for word restaurant language than,
than Swedish.
Much more.
Most languages are.
Yeah.
Well,
and that it's,
it's like,
you know,
one of the things I really about
Dostoyevsky is that this was in notes from
underground.
He,
he just states it very clearly.
He said,
you know,
the one thing that you cannot claim about
the history of the world and he meets
the history of being is that it's rational
and it isn't that he's criticizing
the idea that you could use scientists,
scientific investigation and rationality
to lay out a clear representation of
objective reality.
What he's saying is that if you take the
terrible suffering and malevolence into
account as fundamental realities,
that a rationalist perspective is
absolutely insufficient to tell the story.
And that's,
there's no doubt about that.
It's just rationality just breaks
down in the face of those things.
It hits an obstacle that
it cannot contend with.
So you need something else.
And you know,
there's this great image
of Christ as Pantokrator,
very,
very old image.
Um,
fortunately can't remember which
cathedral it's represented in,
but it's a great image and I'm having
one of them carved for me right now.
It's so,
it's a medieval image of Christ and
his face is divided into two halves.
So it's very asymmetrical and one half
the eyes are different than the facial
expression is different than the other.
And he's also,
he's on portrayed on the top
of the Dome and holding a book.
So the book is sacred,
right?
So that's a great idea
that the book is sacred.
That's a great idea,
man.
And the idea that the word is sacred,
but then the picture also represents
human beings as creatures with one foot in
the,
in the,
in the profane and one foot in the sacred
or one foot in the finite and one foot
in the infinite.
And I actually think that that's,
that's empirically true.
Like we are these weird creatures that
are both finite and infinite at the same
time.
And we have experiences of that,
even like deep religious experiences,
psychedelic experiences for that matter.
Um,
invoke that feeling of
that invoke the reality,
I would say,
of our connection with the infinite.
Now what that infinite is,
so let's call that God.
I mean the Christian ideas that that's
actually outside of time and space
itself,
which is quite a grant,
no ship,
and not the least bit
unsophisticated by the way.
It's a tremendously sophisticated idea
that something actually exists outside
the fabric of time and
space that transcends it,
that they are at the
beginning and at the end.
That's an unbelievably sophisticated idea
and I think that people can experience
that and do quite commonly,
which was why the psychedelic revolution
in the 60s was so absolutely potent.
So these sorts of things can't just be
dismissed with some rationalist sleight
of hand and,
and,
and some discussion of the idea that
Christianity Judeo Christianity,
let's say as some like primitive set of
wish fulfillment superstitions or some
power game.
It's like you just have no
depth of scholarship whatsoever.
If that's what your criticisms are.
I would say when,
when,
uh,
when you,
your ass,
when you ask someone,
do you believe in God?
You,
I ask myself if I say that
I don't believe in God
within me.
When I say eh,
what is different within me when I say
that I don't believe in God compared to a
person that says that
he does believe in God.
I mean is if I feel sort of a irrational,
I wake up or I take a glass of wine and
then suddenly I'm overwhelmed with love
for human kind or for my fellow
man or something like that.
So if I,
if I was a person who will
say that I believed in God,
would that be something?
Is it something qualitatively
different between the person,
between me compared to that person?
You understand what I'm saying?
I haven't quite got that yet.